affaire numéro 1 enregistrée sur le
calendrier du jour concernant sarah
jeune très bien la partie peut commencer
un nouveau visage dans le tribunal de
justin vous êtes trop jeune pour être à
vingt quatre mois
c'est là que j'ai jamais entendu tous
nous avons un petit garçon qui souffrait
de lacérations au visage et d'une
commotion cérébrale tout indique que
cela a été provoqué par sa mère non
[Musique]
je ne comprends pas pourquoi on en
utilise pour déterminer si vous
présentez un risque imminent pour eux
c'est quelqu'un de bien
le tribunal n'aime pas séparer les
enfants de leurs parents
vous ne connaîtrez chapron voulez dire
que vous avez des accès de colère
[Musique]
tu dois laisser tout ça derrière troyes
j'ai vu ce que ça fait de commettre une
erreur est de rendre un enfant un parent
intenable s'est pas achevée
il arrive parfois que des bonnes
personnes fassent des bêtises
[Musique]
quelque chose que vous voulez des
bonjour tout ça sera terminé
je te le promets